hello welcome to this video playing mr.
serious William Paschal kd3 said a mouse
lip no doesn't look like it tries to be
play something that was never ever
played yeah after three moves very VHS
not exactly mr. serious huh this game
came and Bishop is really weird on d too
yeah probably i can just castle I mean
the starting moves kind of suggested
something like h4 might happen something
crazy
sorry for the background so on someone
is what are they doing they're outside
cutting cutting hedges or something
now I'm just occupying the center
playing very normal moves okay now is
recruiting this picture bondi to it's
really weird and or maybe he did
something something wrong or is them on
this tablet or something like that and
sometimes have you have wrong move
entries if you use some client that is
not on a lot honor your typical computer
okay um yeah it's probably going for b
form i can go f4 and just stop it so
always a debatable decision as a format
clamp down on the light squares a five
and then a four okay not quite sure if
that's good but spending more time
probably doesn't make much sense okay so
I'm grabbing this space I give him c4
here but not sure how irrelevant that
really is
let's see for I was considering to play
g5 and then like g6 I think I'm going to
do that 96 possibly then f5 when I Jeff
form yeah that's an interesting
interesting moment now hmm even f5 it's
not entirely entirely wacky and okay
let's do it it's the most aggressive
move I'm not not one hundred percent
convinced i mean i have a couple of
weaknesses but i definitely played in a
movie it's not entirely organized maybe
you can't eat and play night fd2 then 94
something like that could be could be M
possible that my continuation it was a
bit too aggressive but we'll see it's
got two good nights there but i also
have quite some space Knight to g5 and I
can I can go from them
I will be 8 95 those are the moves that
I am going to play anyway okay I would
have preferred to go to six but what can
you do so night f5 here I guess I think
I'm probably happy to trade that
invading pees on d6 hmm now that I think
of it that wasn't such a clear decision
and
hmm Wow so if a chick g6 is going to
take g 6 or noon anyway
I will add a complete hallucination here
I wanted to Kobuk f6 which is which is
of course completely completely wrong oh
wow that that is bad yeah I have to
that's a very bad position
we want to go each form
hmm so how do I set some waveform to get
some conductivity mh4 is some big
problem
love to check that get the Queen down
and back from away from you form I don't
see a great way to do it poor that's a
very unattractive move I had that real
dad move that game i really look like
complete padse looking out of my pawns
on dark squares and so on but i didn't i
didn't see that Queenie 6 resource
correctly okay I'm not not entirely sure
that this was so right what he did but I
guess I get the night
cheb g5 would be good oh I get that in
right now now I'm able to take care
right check check check here first I
mean not that I'm enthusiastic about my
position but I felt like it was even
worse and before check should be for as
a problem and the pure endgame might be
lost if he takes on g6 that's not good
got 12 seconds now he misplayed it
completely but it doesn't matter i have
no time black fits on time yeah now that
was a very deserved gloss yeah I played
it in a very risky fashion strategically
with this G file but ok and it's not
very risky but what I what went wrong is
is this night night coming to d6 I mean
I gave him those two squares for my big
space for the big space advantage but I
made mistakes he am I made mistakes here
and here i should go 95 this is a better
man probably if he goes to the six now
something like that i have two should be
six and he doesn't invade this is the
problem I didn't really take that into
account that he can invade him 26
maybe also yeah it's an annoying move
and I didn't find any decent reply and
this is just wrong my problem was added
pure hallucination I was thinking that
after this I can go here and after the
Queen moves I can take on e4 and get rid
of that night it still wouldn't be great
druke f6 and it's not possible at all
what I have to do is I have to go here
and then it should be kind of okay I
mean nay those pieces don't do much the
engine gives me an advantage in this
position but it's not that I'm not
really so sure about I shouldn't be in
trouble I simply have too much space for
that but yeah here here I'm in trouble
definitely this is a bad position I
don't think he played it well to be
honest after after this this stuff I
don't believe much at least them right
after but okay maybe it is good I don't
know I felt you should have played a
slow away but white is probably better
check check and now here the worst is
over I'm still I'm still in bad shape
but can't promise that it's also much
much easier for why to play yeah yeah it
should be I mean I don't know shouldn't
I be okay my night is dominated but does
he really have that much his King is
also quite open this is given by the
engine with the quality it would be
weird if I members but ok I'm verse 10
second on the clock and sss this ancient
time control this decides the game not
the chest position yeah I spend too much
time looking at this bad position and
trying to solve stuff there ok thanks
for watching